Fox News Alert President Trump getting
ready to hold a news conference any
moment now in the Rose Garden we will
bring it to you live once it happens and
while we wait for that president Trump
and Joe Biden squaring off over how best
to bring back jobs after the pandemic
damaged the economy the former vice
president trying to slice into president
Trump's polling advantage on the economy
Biden quick to criticize President Trump
during his speech today it's got bad
enough didn't even Donald Trump finally
decided to wear a mask in public I'm
glad he made the shift mr. president is
not enough we won't be able to turn the
corner and get American people back to
work safely without presidential
leadership mr. president
open everything now isn't a strategy for
success it's barely a slogan quit
pushing the false choice between
protecting our health and protecting our
economy all it does is endanger our
recovery on both fronts Biden also
calling for two trillion dollars in new
clean energy spending when Donald Trump
thinks about climate change the only
word he can muster is hoax when I think
about climate change the word I think of
his jobs science tells us we have nine
years before the damage is irreversible
we're gonna make historic investments
that will seize the opportunity to meet
this moment in history we're gonna get
to work to living results right away on
day one all right Greg let me ask you a
lot of that stuff in the when it comes
to energy policy do you feel like you
could have heard that before maybe in
the previous administration maybe but it
is bitin economically is kind of
terrifying because he is all in on the
green new deal including this
apocalyptic 9 year vision that is not
based on any science but rather a Oh
see LED hysteria so we're handing our
economy route not over to Joe Biden a
seasoned vice-president or senator we're
handing it over to greta thunderbird in
an old man's suit and that scares me but
another interesting point about when you
compare economies you know the democrats
love to talk about how they're the
masters of the safety net and i want
people to just think about what the
experience of 2020 was when we had a
republican built trump designed economy
that was essentially a safety net that
was tested it was actually tested and it
actually succeeded unlike the safety
nets created by democrats this safety
net was tested by a novel catastrophe
that we've never experienced before in
our lives
nobody has starved we have made it
through we have made sacrifices but we
have we are getting it done largely
because of this incredible economy that
allowed for a safety net to occur to
give out these payments to make sure
people were okay this is a republican
built safety net that just blew the
doors off any democrat safety net of the
last 50 years meanwhile what are the
Dems pushing an apocalyptic vision that
chooses the mob over the individual you
see somebody like Trump pushing for
achievement Biden is pushing the
politics of envy and that's code that
will get us nowhere in the long term or
even the short term Jesse this was the
second phase of the Biden rollout on his
economic plan last week was by American
today is all about energy and if you
think about the Midwest and how
important it is for both candidates to
try to win in 2020 what how do you think
Biden thread threaded that needle today
between going after the progressives who
were talking about the apocalyptic
climate change issue as Gregg was
pointing out but also this idea for
additional jobs in the clean energy
market can he do that Biden just
plagiarized Bernie Sanders environmental
plan or Bernie Bros just put a gun to
Biden's head and Biden said fine I'll
say whatever you want me to say I mean
this is literally a o'seas green new
deal here two trillion dollars on wind
and solar do you really think Joe
Biden or any of his people can pull it
off first of all solar only works
economically and environmentally in the
United States in the southwest wind
power only works in the Great Plains in
the Midwest but I guarantee you all of
this trillions of dollars it's just
going to go to lobbyists and donors and
they're gonna put some like windmill and
Maine and a solar panel in Montana and
it's just not gonna work it's just
another boondoggle because they're not
smart enough to be able to pull it off
the smartest thing to say if I were Joe
Biden would say I'd be for fracking but
he went so far left in the primary he
doesn't like fracking now because
natural gas is the cleanest energy
source we're ever gonna have and God
blessed the United States with mountains
and mountains of it and we're just
sitting on piles of it so you can even
balance a few solar panels and some
windmills with this beautiful clean
natural gas and call it a day but he
just won't do it and child Trump can
come at him and just say you're an
economic illiterate you don't know what
you're talking about this is basically
aoc on steroids get out of here and let
me rebuild the economy because Americans
trust me more than you by double-digits
one when the Biden campaign was putting
us on PR right before the speech
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes was also
tweeting taking a lot of credit for the
speech does that help Biden keep his
moderate label I think that you know a
lot of this back and forth over the
economic policy at this moment Dana I
don't think that it really matters a
whole lot if what we're aiming at is the
November election because I think at the
moment the urgent policy stuff leads us
to a referendum on Donald Trump and
right now Trump's beaten Trump because
if you look at big ticket items like you
know do we send our kids back to school
in the fall Axios
I post has a poll out today 70% of
Americans think that's too risky to send
our kids back to school and that
includes like 79
percent of Democratic Republicans know
I'm talking about the election because I
think that as we aim towards energy as
we aim towards something like how do you
get this economy going for the high
percentage of people I think it's like
11 12 percent now out of work and you
think about the fact that we have
arguments coming from this White House
over extending unemployment benefits at
the end of this month I think again
Donald Trump is out of sync with the
American people but it you know it's
like when 5.4 million Americans lose
their health insurance that's a big
economic issue and whereas Trump he's
trying to undo Obamacare so to me these
are urgent policy issues way beyond
whether or not we rebuild the
infrastructure which i think is fairly
sensible whether we rebuild a
manufacturing sector this is what's
determining the election yeah okay okay
Katie we do know that across the board
President Trump does beat Donna Joe
Biden on matters of the economy I
haven't seen it broken down too much in
terms of energy you were at the over at
the White House today tell me your
perspective on all this I was at the
White House today I had the chance to
interview President Trump he did talk
about the election and Joe Biden and
said that the economy will crash of Joe
Biden wins the election he talked about
how Joe Biden has been in office and
around Washington DC for almost five
decades and yet now all of the sudden is
hitching his wagon to this green New
Deal 2.0 and look you know you can't
argue as Joe Biden has that you want to
bring back American manufacturing while
also at the same time try to promise
some kind of green new deal because the
regulations in this country are ready
due to the Environmental Protection
Agency and a whole host of other
overreach but the government had
prevented manufacturing from coming back
to this country and it's going to be
very expensive for the average family
you remember in 2016 when Hillary
Clinton made the mistake of saying we're
going to put coal miners out of business
that's exactly what this will do
electricity prices will go up and we
tried this before the Obama
administration
which Joe Biden was a part of lost 500
million dollars of taxpayer money on
Solyndra which was the solar panel
coming company that they just gave a
bunch of recovery money to that was not
successful so these two things do not go
together you can't promise manufacturing
in America while also promising all
these regulations which do not allow any
of the ingenuity and manufacturing to
Kate to take place here for viewers that
have been watching for many years you
will remember the fond days when we
talked about Solyndra